- one two nine three one five seven
three one hey guys first of all thank
you for clicking you're about to watch a
new video or another video on YouTube
and before you - one two nine three one
five seven three one you are getting
value out of my youtube videos what I'm
doing in my text community is bonkers
it's instant it's access it's exclusive
and it's just been a lot of fun and I
just enjoy the texting back and forth
and vodka you went to nine three one
five seven three one I'm sure they're
editing something team and how you do it
please join my texting community and now
enjoy this YouTube video this portion is
like with me so I think this is one you
need to get selfish like you'd ask your
question
hiring is guessing firing as no like you
gotta go fast that's how you get [ __ ]
done that's a bigger stuff out
this is the television and the
television is the radio for these
[ __ ] what school and where you
based also what was your name I'm sorry
Shelly that's okay awesome I understand
a digital plan download download PDF
coffee table in that so that's one
Monday things in front of your outlets
down understood we use we build the CRM
with a lot of extras SAS understood cry
bleed revenue yep understood what do you
base any individual business or is it a
franchise model one company that's
servicing this general area or awesome
pleasure from
the prestige brand and the character is
easy market and through that 30 offices
in five agents and change so sold out
and want to be back to my apologies is
now a coaching company which is I
understand hi a part of it
and you do that as a service for others
yes understood well I say I see got it
you have media properties or you have
personal your personal property yours
its you understood awesome
and your client in that scenario is the
school system the individual schools and
individual schools or have enough
autonomy at a superintendent or a
principal level to make that kind of
call
nice cool that's really neat what's up K
how good to see you guys I know you guys
super well I guess actually let's do it
that way I mean actually once you do see
ourselves for context for everybody else
in the furniture business in Florida and
your names for everybody
awesome so let's go back around look
like let's rock and roll what can i yeah
what can I answer thank thank you
that's very smooth thank you for saying
that so so in that in a world where
obviously I'm always so like petrified
to always bring the most value I think
what's gonna be interesting and it's a
really fun starting off point it's super
important to think about are you looking
for affirmation or are you looking to
fill in something that I was unable to
touch on since I have to go somewhat
broad at times and and both are cool
like you know I think it's wild to think
about how valuable affirmation is like
sometimes it's just the push you know
like I always talk about the story of
like being late to swimming it wasn't
formation it was that my sister started
swimming I heard it playing knock hockey
and the thought that my six-year-old
sister has a nine year old was gonna
swim before me forced me to run jump in
the pool as a non swimmer scared
shitless of swimming and literally necks
eight minutes figure out that I was
swimming and then spent the next decade
trying to make pretend I swam first but
it's one of the few things she didn't
let me like win so you know yeah I
really appreciate that comment and then
and then what that makes me do is tell
that story to say hey are you thinking
about it is gonna be affirmation cuz you
know and you've set felt the nuances and
what's to double-down or is there
something I haven't been able to touch
on that you've been curious about or
which I'm sure some of you know this I
think so much of my strength is pulling
from opposite directions so if you
listen long enough the amount of
potential contradictions while what I
think it is is balancing from both sides
may lead to a clarification need because
if you're not pulling from both then you
can't pull it off I have so I think a
lot of times I like band I'm throwing so
many ingredients at everybody that what
I'm starting to realize is like [ __ ] all
of it doesn't work if you're missing one
of these like I'm like why is it working
and why is it not why are people walking
in and like completely like weather from
external internal transforming and why
are others not which led me to
insecurities and all that stuff but when
that's done I'm like right you need to
do all these things it's like a really
well cooked meal you if you hold off the
spice then it's just not like there's a
lot there so I think that's a good way
to frame this up for everybody to think
about I don't know if that's inspired
maybe that a question but yep
right is their disappointment in the
system with that yes really working
you're not sure if it's in you or not
because you had that you had the ability
to not even have the ability to do it
well I think I think even the fact that
you're thinking about it already makes
me optimistic that you have it in you
the fact you even recognize that
question means that it's something that
you value I mean here we are um you're
nervous to ask me a question and the
place where you naturally go is actually
caring about culture which already makes
me know that you're probably gonna do a
decent job of culture by over valuing
human beings it's not super complicated
if you're playing long like I'm not
mother Teresa I'm just playing long I
mean when I look at d-roc Mickey and
Jesse and think about we're now over 20
[ __ ] years of collective and just
three people I'm looking at right and
Nick I mean like this is ludicrous like
we keep people maybe Nick is doing such
interesting [ __ ] on his own right now
and I watch that and I'm just like
pumped I'm rooting for him so heavy I
only I don't even have time I'm so busy
I don't even have time to tell him that
directly I use it these moments to
double dip till I keep telling him keep
going
it's true though you know and like like
that's like not the way Mike my dad
would have been would have fired Nick at
the first indication of a leisure
apparel brand that he had he felt like
everybody had to do it for hit like you
know you just lean into people it's not
super complicated [ __ ] or sitting
here because I promised Mickey that if
he joined vaynermedia I'd open something
in the south that is real talk
there was no good strategic reason to
open this office you know other than I
promised Mickey you know and he luckily
went to like baseball camp here after I
came on a trip here and like fell in
love with the city so I would say it's
actually stunningly easy do you value
people more than you Belo short-term
profit most people don't which is fine I
don't but it's really easy when you care
about it I think where you have to be
careful of is where I'm at my weakest
which is you create entitlement because
you lack candor when you need to make
people actually perform on a business I
think my shortcoming my kriptonite has
been ironically something nobody would
believe on this way that I communicate
publicly which is I've been too soft
which is created entitlement a lot of
stuff I put in the system is trying to
coach myself into it fire faster be more
you know like these are real things you
know so I'm a bleeding-heart like I'd be
a great guidance counselor and a great
therapist and a lot of other great
things you know it's where some of the
crossover is different than me than
others that people have worked problem
different and that's why I feel
different and it's true and it makes me
have less economics in the short term
and people out there make fun of me for
that it's only because they're judging
in the second quarter let's see how this
all plays out so it's real easy just
choose it you know I think the question
becomes you wait wait you might be
struggling with this you see certain
things that do work for that business on
doing things that maybe you naturally
wouldn't do but you haven't seen the
alternative yet you're like alright but
dad or whoever a your mom would they do
that and [ __ ] that actually does make
more money you just haven't seen the
alternative yet
my brother my dad others make more
profit short term but they never build
the size of businesses that I built so
last time I checked like 5% of a billion
is more than 29% of 40 million last time
I checked you have any questions I know
it's early but there might be something
but there might be something yeah yes
like fully committing to it I think by
doing the work to be educated on
everything by reading watching videos by
putting in the education work the
biggest issue when people go from
something bigger to something smaller is
the speed and the needs become way
different there's so many corporate so
many people in corporate right now are
trying to join smaller startups and they
obviously come and talk to me because
I've known the person we had a client
from Unilever you know you worked on you
know Libre and that's why I thought Jen
Bremner i sat down with yesterday you
know yeah who like you know we didn't
necessarily have the greatest run with
and she's looking to make a move from
Unilever to a midsize company and you
know I even though we didn't have the
greatest rub I do were I do actually
think she's got chops and so I was
giving her advice of like hey you know
we were talking about that today with
the Sascha group Sascha versus vein are
like you guys like you guys care in a
different way like it's your lively or
something it's not even caring surviving
versus you know getting a different job
somewhere else like so the speed in
which but you still have things that you
can really bring to the table
you have to go through the filter of
practicality and speed instead of
ideology and lack of speed and
something you have to get used to I know
I know it because I just I'm really good
at pattern recognition and like oh it's
why I listen yeah I talk a lot about me
listening over talking cuz I've always
especially I have such a bad rap because
I do interrupt my guests on my podcast
but it's cuz I already know I know what
they're saying and I'm thinking about
the audience not my guests and if
they're about to spend nine minutes and
I know they have to leave for another
appearance somewhere because that's just
so everybody knows I'm not like this
chill podcast where it's what you do for
the day and that's all I do for a living
like we both my guests and I are on a
very tight schedule and I'm saying to
myself this woman this man is about to
talk for nine minutes about something
this audience fully knows and is going
to be complete vanilla so now I'm gonna
interrupt add my two cents that brings
value and move them forward and so I'm
willing to get judged and ridiculed by
my audience to bring more value to my
audience
I believe my interrupting on my podcast
is the single nicest thing I'm doing for
my audience while my audience scrutinize
it me for the most but I'm willing to
take that scrutiny to bring value
because what the audience doesn't know
is what the show would have looked like
if I let them run which is we would have
gotten to two things pure vanilla and
see you tomorrow
that is about being consumer centric
that is about pattern recognition that's
about knowing and so just hearing it and
knowing it which goes to the most
interesting part which is you two can
win you just have to have humility and
honesty with each other and
over-communicate instead of thinking it
in your heads
yep hated they never received the system
and so by the destiny position to be
successful the insurance that helped me
on that day and so he hated the song to
work on for three years to get that
meeting you can be you can actually be
creative
go figure let me give you a couple of
quick piece of ice on that 83 percent of
somebody else is better than 100 percent
of just you the number one mistake that
people make when they start to delegate
is they make a subjective opinion in
their mind of what that should look like
and that's not the way to scale
100 percent 100 that's why I jumped in
back to you know that's the game the
game is that I never even talked to
Dirac like after after I when we started
the blog I had to watch a little bit
because I had to teach him hey your
complete and that's who he was at that
raw state mindset is to make the best
YouTube video yeah can't put the part
where I'm telling Mickey to fire Susan
she doesn't know yet
like that's gonna be a problem you know
he can't be you can't put the part of
after we have the client meeting I look
at one of my teammates and say that
clients a [ __ ] idiot
that's bad like so at first I had to
watch but that was that was help me here
11 episode I'm not I'm not a lot of
episodes and since then I don't watch
anything I don't watch anything now on
Instagram I'm titling those things I'm
writing all the copy there's a way for
you to come in at 3rd and a half base
just don't judge the dugout 2/3 and 1/2
base and also know that in an hour
you're putting out another piece of
content you know especially when you
have the unluck Cherie of having a viral
hit too many people then are looking for
that moment again yeah it's a real
killer if you get unlucky and have
something go crazy you then get stuck
looking for crazy which means you stop
making makes sense you know for me I
make a hundred pieces of content that
add up to 4 million views instead of
being crippled for nine days making one
video hoping for four million views that
gets thirty seven thousand views it's
also recognizing the second year over
focused on monetization is the second
that you're limiting your upside so to
me it's more about can you get into a
mental place of realizing how little do
you need to
if so that you don't think about
monetization at all
every time you pander to the
monetization you are limiting your
upside because inherently you start
making things for the monetization now
for the audience you get into a new
machine your own machine you just your
it's whether you know whether it's
authenticity like whatever word we want
to put against it the second your day is
about waking up and figuring out how
much money YouTube or Facebook is gonna
make to you versus what's going to make
somebody really want to watch this is
the day you start the process of not
being able to win you know fund it is
that not a single piece of my content
back to a lot of business model here's
you know what it feels like to not make
any content with the thought of how does
this create a top of the funnel scenario
to a landing page that converts to my
livelihood yeah you know looking at some
of you knowing your business models that
puts me in a position of being able to
win that's why it's happening it also is
why you're here whoever brings the most
value wins not whoever creates the
perception of the most value that person
wins in the short term let me tell you a
couple things real quick I'm at that is
absolutely true but don't think of it in
a traditional way think of it as more of
like everybody's gonna monetize we're
all individuals everyone here has the
actual ability to pull this off it's
just that some people will make 17
dollars a year and some will make 17
million but there are plenty of female
like the more you spend time in the
classic model the more likely you'll get
up side all you need to think about is
how do you bring the most value period
end of story
and then it will manifest I never think
about like everybody I see who wins does
a much better job of not trying to be
some variation of a sentence applied
against somebody who's already famous
don't even think that way think 100
percent how do I make content that
people will like
that's how you put the chickens in the
tub you need to basically live in a
humble framework in perpetuity and
that's how you get the most stuff just
them just them then because that leads
to creativity like if I care you know
we've been our most creative when I
finally broke through of saying over and
over don't pander to the Machine even
though I knew and I would tell dear
uncle my [ __ ] we're pandering to the
Machine on Instagram like we know what's
working and the second I finally finally
like after a month because I'm like [ __ ]
you dude don't be a hypocrite do your
thing
that's when if you look at the last
hundred posts I've had they've been far
more creative that's where the cartoons
come from that's where the unsub upside
down post comes from it's just where the
creativity is coming from and inevitably
there will be a piece of content that
changes the course because of it all
that all the trash talk content you know
that over indexes that would have never
happened if I wasn't willing to do
something that wasn't obvious of course
curation DJing always works we're busy
and if I can go to the best finds and
you can tell me what the four best memes
of they are that saves me time curation
works coz it saves time we want time
saving so they all I think text
messaging is the most interesting
platform emerging in the world so that
would be my first choice cuz you'll get
100 percent consumption against your
list messenger does a very good job of
that as well
whatsapp can make you go global so like
email still works
not you know like so there's a I know
but yeah a hundred percent all all of it
that's what I do it's why I always say
watch what I do not what I say you want
audio got you you want video got you you
want email got you well written yep
LinkedIn could look cartoons good I
don't care no friction for consumption
what I have got the right side the two
rods now how much are those how to build
a coffee table how much do they cost
compel how much what do you spend on
acquisition and where do you spend it
all organic that's great you know why
that's great
cuz that's terrible correct in the war
and again in a world because I know a
lot of you have this context you can't
underestimate how underpriced this media
is like Instagram swipe up ads for you
with the right content would be
uncomfortable conversion pay to get 9
pay to get 9 pay 3 get 9 at scale just
how businesses go from 4 million to 40
million in a year because once because
once something works you can pour
lighter fluid in perpetuity the plans
hire and invest yes it's getting a math
person you've got the art down you need
math I by the way I believe that to be
true then you got math as a commodity
art is not got it if you're like me math
and art you always I gave up on math a
long time ago I'm gonna math I
understand what it cost to I understand
the concept of pay nine dollars for a
wine customer and look at the back end
and my profits 11 and keep going until
that doesn't work and then if I'm upside
down then I think about the lifetime
value and I look over the best wine
store in the country so they keep coming
back
so actually 11 is okay most companies
it's not because they don't have return
business number the minute right but I
gave all that up because everybody can
do math meaning anybody that can do math
does math because it doesn't move art
moves by the second
the culture moves I'd hire a math person
where are you based
so there's a million ways to do this
right eh you know we'll try to send you
some recommendations I don't know who
former Vayner employees are that we live
in nationally you know there might yeah
there might be like you could you could
hire it I think one of the great moves
is to hire a small agency and then steal
their employee you know like like put
out you know like that's a good idea
like interview ten small Facebook
agencies and Nashville and meet them all
be like oh I really like Karen she seems
sharp hire that one and then try to
steal her yeah you know what I don't
like about that yet is you're making all
that judgment off the history of organic
and I don't know what the upside is yet
on proper media I would sell I would
sell them I would sell them individually
at the highest dollar amount and test
them how many different products are I
would test them all at scale across all
LinkedIn Facebook Twitter whatever for
six months have a real understanding and
then make the decision that you're
asking right now off of far more data it
might not be when you're actually
arbitrage against the most underpriced
attention it might be but it might not
be there's also the question of if you
have a ton more customer you pay 14
against nine first of all why nine like
if it's costing 14 and you raise it to
17 and it works and now you're using
that audience to triple your sponsorship
business a lot of things that people
don't do is they don't play chess they
go to binary if I've got those revenue
streams that you have I would say to
myself you know what I'll break even on
the products because I want to go to
scale but I'm gonna siphon that
attention from the products on this
content so that I can ask 10x on the
sponsorship side it's kind of a I got it
I got it
you're you're the reverse because that
was the cadence and how you did it you
can also reverse it back right all of a
sudden I may want to pay you a million
dollars a year they may you've got to
play on both fronts to find out clouds
and dirt right when the reason that
works for me is like that's how I think
like you know always have to play on
multiple fronts because it might be the
upside down thing
could you imagine you know and
businesses are more likely to overspend
got it
so you might be able to get a half a
million dollar sponsorship that makes no
[ __ ] sense
which then allows you say oh [ __ ] now I
see what you see where I'm going right
it's more likely you get grossly
overpaid by a sponsor to then use those
dollars to sell lower funnel than the
other way around because that's the
market got it okay so my what the entire
you know 72 products
[Music]
there's no way to condense 72 different
value props quickly I think one you need
to look at it how how long have you been
doing it you may want to figure out if
you have 72 features versus 72 products
first of all you also need to figure out
which ten products most convert it's
like any retail store or any comm like
what retailers are starting to figure
out I mean this is the big challenge I'm
gonna push to my wine store
it used to be hey Dad it was my agenda
we're gonna the biggest selection in the
[ __ ] world we win it's actually that
became that becomes crippling and I've
been trying to push my dad to create
these WL fifty stores where they're tiny
stores with only 50 wines from Wine
Library you know because people don't
actually want choice it's why wine
texworks one product of a very simple
boom I don't want to think so I think
you're making people think too much so I
think that there's probably four
products that are 80% of the actual
action and that's where my comms would
come in and you might be going on too
much of an ideology that I have to get
to all of these things I think you need
to really look at usage what I would do
is look at usage that's why I asked you
how long I would look at all the usage
of the product which is what's great
about a SAS business and say [ __ ]
actually these six things are 80% and
that's gonna happen because some of
those products are dog [ __ ] and some of
them are the [ __ ] thing you just
that's the nature of the game right that
who's buying your product LinkedIn bro
need to make a hot you need to make 25
piece of content a day for LinkedIn
specific when people think of
salespeople as one thing versus a sales
woman who happens to be a Falcons fan
that's a whole different you can my game
is in perpetuity people like sales
people and I'm like no they're like how
do I make a hundred pieces of content
like okay well first of all there's 50
states
so there's 50 hey Alabama
hey salespeople in Alabama it's your boy
that's already 50 because I can promise
you when you run ads against small
businesses or sales organization in
Alabama and it starts with books up
Alabama that already does better than it
says what's up its your boy Gary I know
it's true you start then saying you said
then do that piece of content when the
Auburn Alabama game is going on and you
make some sort of reference point that
says if you're an Auburn fan and leave a
comment or if you're a Bama fan leave a
comment and LinkedIn whoever wins the
game that person gets 10% off the other
one gets to cry twice and so if you look
at the collective reaction to that idea
that's why I win because I'm in the game
of ideas and then just making [ __ ]
LinkedIn is uncomfortably underpriced
organic let alone paid you need to go if
you made no content anywhere else which
is so against my macro thesis but if you
didn't and you made a hundred piece a
day for LinkedIn that was specific to
psychographic demographic location age
gender sex you will win it's really I
know it will and what's really awesome
for me is it's gonna work good it's kind
of like believing that if you eat well
and you workout every day you'll look
better I know you believe it I'm telling
you to [ __ ] do it
nothing meaning meaning you can't
imagine you know what that would be like
if if we were like kids and only wanted
to eat candy and I literally walked in
right now
with a [ __ ] truck full of candy and
you'd be like yo where else is there
candy I'm like [ __ ] we can't eat
all this candy
that was that was the question
yep yes I'll bring them value well like
that's a challenge too you know like
that's not so easy and then start
correct and and start reading comments
ask questions one of the things that
very few people do is make content to
ask questions I love that because then
you get answers in the comments which
then leads you to the next piece of
content so much of my content is
actually not made for any other thing
than an insight to a hypothesis it's how
I got to all the content that I talked
about today I there was no strategy
session where I'm like I'm gonna be
content about parenting that was a thing
that happened out of making all the
content that made me get to the
realization of so many opportunities and
vulnerabilities that's why it resonates
it the reason my content resonates is it
comes from the community markets in like
genres or in physical markets okay and
and and and the reality is and I
understand where you're going with this
is you know in your soul that you're not
doing enough to actually see the full
results of it so you're just kind of
caught in this hamster wheel of half
pregnant and then like I get it I'm
emotional about this because there's
like ten things I try to get Wine
Library to do they did it for like oh
like there was a
incredible concept I had of pricing
everyone in the store at a1 the bottle
level a six bottle level and a 12 bottle
level like that's it like case discount
like it [ __ ] was going to be big
literally because Passover was coming up
my dad wanted to put kosher wine in that
spot tore down the whole concept for
three days worth of business of no money
and like destroyed like didn't give it
the full chance to do what it was gonna
do what I think you need to decide is
profitability the answer to your
question is actually very easy you know
exactly even tell the way you asked it
you actually know it's right you just
have to make less money you have to plop
someone there or plop it longer and eat
the crow of no results because the
[ __ ] needs nine months to get to the
results you're in the sales transaction
mindset not in the brand building
mindset and you know it and now the
question becomes can you afford it and
you know that becomes the thing I don't
know when a moment like this but then
when the person says no and you know I'm
always pushing and you guys know this
make less money this year to build
something bigger make less money that's
how you do it it's called the best thing
in your [ __ ] and then there's also audit
the 20% of things you spend money on
that are [ __ ] garbage your worst
employee some dumb thing that you're
leaving paying attention to that your
Unruh currently getting billed for like
your your snacks are over pray you know
that was the big brouhaha Vayner this
year I eliminated a we were spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars on bars
and four percent of the people were
eating it so I [ __ ] eliminated of
course everyone acted like they ate in
every day of their [ __ ] life and I'm
[ __ ] Hitler but you know but that was
just a good business decision based on
what was actually happening yeah they're
good they're scrapping you know I'm
talking about [ __ ] New Yorkers got it
that's the [ __ ] answer I apologize
and if you can really find a system
where you can get the highest kind of
person to make the impact at the lowest
possible cost you can really scale the
[ __ ] out of this you know when you're
looking for a Swiss Army knife right she
he's got it like you gotta find an
entrepreneurial tendency person right I
heard that makes sense sales and
marketing or not owning the company well
the good news on that is that's like a
brain and a heart yeah it's like you
know like there that's honestly if you
really synthesized what I've been up to
and even so far halfway through people
think they're marketing but they're
actually selling totally not only not
only doesn't it have to it shouldn't to
get the maximum upside now look some
owners are not meant for content yours
may not this is where you get into
Snoopy like maybe your breakthrough is a
cartoon in stick figure form and that
cartoon is the is the thing that can do
everything but yes for everybody here
who's doing any kind of personal
branding like I do far more so much more
works for me because I'm into wine and
the Jets and garage saling and all of it
people try to theoretically say is wrong
you're stretched in you what do you
represent that I mean when I started
garage saleing on trash talk and on
Instagram so many of my smartest friends
hit me up immediately like on Instagram
story first day before trash talk I'm
like yo you can't do this you look
stupid this is crazy like you're like on
the verge of becoming one of the most
important business people like what are
people gonna think I'm like the [ __ ] are
you talking about you mean
you want me to pander to the ivory
towers what are people to think I think
that hundreds of thousands of people are
about to make an extra thousand dollars
a year that they need for a better
family vacation and their life will be
better and I'm not worried about the
[ __ ] CEO a [ __ ] you know worried
about the fact that I garage sale yes of
course I can I think more importantly
the question becomes the voice needs to
be something that brings the most value
to the audience and so the voice takes
on a lot of layer of course it can be
you but let me give an example me I
think the voice should be all of the
following you when you're out to dinner
with your girlfriends you in the office
the founder when he or she is golfing
the family like what people understand
is it's not a singular voice there's a
million different reasons why I would
consider letting you cut my lawn or
hedge by flowers or whatever [ __ ] you do
right there might be a million different
things and like how you do that on
Facebook and LinkedIn and Instagram and
Twitter and all these platform
you know you know on Google where it's
all intent based marketing you know that
needs that is more sales Google AdWords
is selling not marketing on Instagram
it's [ __ ] marketing it's visual right
so don't get caught in that place where
I think a lot of us were taught to do
which is like what's the voice
even if it was just you I have a funny
feeling there's at least 13 different
versions of you given the circumstances
you're in and the funny feeling you're a
totally different gal when you're best
friends on a weekend in Vegas on a girls
trip then you are in this room right now
you should see do when he's with his
[ __ ] boys should go directly to jail
so I think that I think that that that's
creative contextually at scale there
knowing enough about Chattanooga
there's the hills and across there's
different things going on here right and
they need to see different things some
of them are only going to play at a
certain price point others want you know
a different equation so that that's how
you have to reverse engineer the
attention what what is the company spent
money on historically or currently yep
all word-of-mouth Direct Mail yeah you
know Direct Mail and print are great
because Facebook can do better that's
where you have to take twenty to fifty
percent of that budget and show them how
much scrutiny are you under by ownership
a lot right it's small business yeah I
believe that to be true
there's no reason and scaping business
Chattanooga should not have a large
budget but why do you exist
they understand that marketing matters
like I would argue that that's
incredibly progressive to begin with an
employee for a family-owned business
that is in landscaping to have a
marketing executive means that somebody
there understands it's awesome
I think influencer marketing you should
absolutely right now open your phone go
to Instagram search Chattanooga find the
top posts and DM people and offer them
free service so if you go to Instagram
one of the things funny below call
business you're searching the city that
you're in then they give you all the
pictures then there's top or recent you
hit top you click it you see if
somebody's visiting Chattanooga for the
you know for something or do they live
here if they live here you DM them and
say very simply hey I think you're an
influencer in Chattanooga I believe that
if you took a photo or made a video on
your actual feed not in your stories
because that disappears too quick about
us and we will give you in return
a to
or 500 or bladder no the business will
have free service for it but that's good
for our business and good for you two
out of every ten will say yes five out
of every ten will say yes that's a whole
lot of local awareness tactics first
year what people don't know is that
eighty percent of my comments were stay
in your lane wine boy meanwhile I was
like I was a businessman before you knew
me like I'm in my lane but yes it's
worth less than you think
yes I get it it just it's worth less
than you think and it's um this is why
these are so fun it's only worth
something they're willing to use you or
bring awareness to you in a literal
sense of is it worth something in a raw
business form the answer is the only
audience of Wine Library that was worth
something to me in a transition of
business in theory was people that also
had interest in business which many
didn't and there was are the ones that
called me a sellout or I hate you I miss
you or whatever they said others came
along it's not worth something you know
what's worth something in my opinion
well I would launch your absolute
business I would ask everybody in theory
if they'd like to hire you and then I
would create content around the first
ten people that hired you
and then if nobody wanted to hire you I
would pick ten people and do it for free
that's it yep yep yep yep the other
thing you can do and this works for a
lot of the people that just ask
questions so I want to make sure they're
gonna hear this you could start a Q&A
show look one of the I always talk about
watch what I do not what I say my
reintroduction into content was the
askgaryvee show
my audience was not that big at that
point because I had transitioned to
business but I went dark for two years
building vaynermedia and the way that I
reintroduced myself was off a small
bass to be able to create content
because we weren't blogging yet I didn't
have a podcast yet was to start a show
where people ask me questions on Twitter
which off that was my biggest base which
led to some awareness because they had
to use the hashtag so now people see
they're asking me a question so that got
me by accident viewers I then picked
five of them answered it put it out for
freedom was incredibly valuable you can
do that with HR questions you could
literally put right now on your LinkedIn
I'm doing this I don't know if you
notice by the way who's got HR macro
questions take five of the questions
from the LinkedIn comments record either
video or audio you answering them and
then we put out the content into the
system the HR content that I put out on
LinkedIn and obviously I'm off a big
base but there but it's standardized
always over indexes it is the
conversation I think that's good I think
I think I think both are good but the
asking is easier quicker more scale
because you're doing a lot of work to
get to that one piece of content
LinkedIn I would also very much consider
doing a podcast and I think this would
work for you I think it would think it
works for a lot of people I mean back to
being the mayor like if you started the
Chattanooga business podcast you you're
your landscaping business the
Chattanooga business podcast and
interviewed business people here it
would just bring awareness randomly this
is awesome keep going
I love you love it's just it's the life
I'm living I'm like I want to be the
greatest entrepreneur of this generation
and I do not think that comes solely
from making the most money I have to
give back to the system and they both
work in hand
unbelievable unbelievable love because
it's and it's and it's gonna lead to and
it's gonna lead the business it also it
also lead it also leads you it also
leads you to go to the open rest the new
restaurant that opens you walk in and
somebody says Heidi and you're like whoa
they know who I am
and then and then after you get off the
one second high of like am i famous you
you then convert it into a business
opportunity I'm far more proud of being
the architect of Gary Vee
than being Gary Vee because I know what
it means for business I mean it's
amazing to take selfies and I love that
I like people and I like attention
that's fine but that is a distant second
compared to the actual strategy behind
it it's great you're on your way you
need to create a way to make more
content Q&A is a great way to do it
by reaching out to them that's right I
know it's such a simple answer but
that's actually the answer now the
question becomes how what size what do
you do when you reach out to and what
value proper are you offering them of
course you're a bender you're a bender
here's what I would do I would reach out
to all the businesses around you email
them or let me go old school one like
like one of my favorite moves is
overwhelming somebody with something
physical it doesn't work on me because I
get so much mail and so many things sent
to me and I don't like stuff that we
have we actually have a the reverse
problem where I feel bad that people are
sending me like five hundred dollar
items that I own I mean you know I do
stealing of em you know and selling uh
money of it you know right like it's
really like actually something we have
to figure out but on in the reverse if
you were to send somebody something that
looked like a wedding invitation high
quality or like a fruit basket or
influential marketing just you know
homemade cookies from a local company
that you want to give some support to
and inside we're a bunch of cookies in
tick-tock and Instagram logos with a
really nice letter that said look hi
Nancy you're the CMO of Aflac in Atlanta
we think influencer marketing is being
greatly underused we've been doing it
for five years this is where it gets
important in 30 40 where we October on
November 19th at a private room at this
hot restaurant in Atlanta I am hosting a
free you know kind of dinner and talk
around influencer marketing for the
first 25 people that respond to these
beautiful cookies I hope this caught
your attention I hope you understand
what I'm actually saying here if you'd
like to RSVP here's a link where you can
call
that would work now you've spent $2,000
on cookies mail invitations a private
room wine and here's what happens when
you send a hundred of those three people
common and you're sitting there and you
like [ __ ] Gary I [ __ ] we said all this
money this and that but three becomes
six and six becomes 18 and god forbid
you're good at writing a letter and god
forbid the cookies look good maybe the
first one is actually 39 maybe even have
a problem and it goes the other way it
goes one of two ways it's oh wait for
some reason nothing ever ends up being
the middle it's ends up being two people
and you're like [ __ ] Gary or it becomes
89 people you have like four months of
events lined up and you're like he's a
[ __ ] genius but it's gonna be one of
those two it's gonna be one of those to
go direct a brand notice what I'm doing
break through the noise and give them
something of value with no expectation
in return and if you make that dinner a
conversation if this was one big funnel
for you to pay me five hundred thousand
dollars a year at Vayner everything out
of my mouth would be different I'm
looking to never see you again and get
an email from you that says I love you
that's different that's what everybody
should be doing that's how you build
something monsterous agencies care about
agencies it doesn't matter
agencies care about agencies PNL it
doesn't matter what they think it will
always be here cuz John Wayne is no
different than you to word-of-mouth from
a human always will play and I think we
haven't even started every 16 year old
in America wants to be an influencer
that is their number one goal in life
that will mean much more supply and the
demand is unparalleled there's a reason
there's traffic when somebody gets into
an accident
the reason we rubberneck is because
we're [ __ ] nosy there's a reason that
reality TV is a monster even though it's
not real cuz we're [ __ ] nosy we like
each other it's why we're not dead
there's been bombs that wipe us off the
[ __ ] face the earth for sixty years
and we're still here
humans like humans
it's very sweet thank you yeah yeah yeah
that's right
[Music]
yeah because you'd see that what's so
great about this and why I think this
has been a successful program is some of
this [ __ ] like like this is where it
gets good what's really great about this
is when you have a product that has a
cost of entry of the size of this you
have real people we're pretty intense
about how we scrutinize anybody trying
to come in and one insight given to a
real person like that's why strategy
exists like nobody really wants to pay
for strategy like it seems like a bad
idea kind of in some way but the
blueprint matters and I can get very
specific and there's been a lot of stuff
I feel good about here and I'm like
excited to see how it manifests so go
ahead yes yes but that but I think you
may also know that's a focus group of
one you know like I history is the
subject that I got the best grades in
and I continue to use it every day in
business cuz i pattern recognized on
prior things I already know what's gonna
happen with Netflix and Amazon and all
the oh TTS because that's what cable did
to network teams like I already know and
more importantly something that I've
done a much better job of clarifying and
I'm trying to do a better job of is
there are plenty of people that get
value out of learning that way I write
books cuz people learn that way and as
you can probably imagine active is
always gonna resonate more with me right
like that that could have potentially
been the thing that unlocked somebody
dictating to me information to memorize
next Friday was not going to cut it for
the way that I was built but actually
being like I could have absolutely
learned
thing from working a garden to
understanding the process of those nine
weeks to make something happen that I
could be deploying in something I'm
doing today
I just wasn't given the chance because
everything is so one-size-fits-all a
hundred percent yes yeah it's really
cool it's awesome
[Music]
[Music]
right and and you know that framework
also like I've never been a monster fan
of like hey client can you make a
testimonial so I can put it like it
which is why I love the idea of pod cat
like host the party right like if you
had if you started something called the
progressive principle podcast and you
interviewing people and yeah you'll
touch on two minutes of like hey Sara
thanks for being here obviously we met a
couple months ago with my business but
that's not what we're here for
tell me why you even said yes to my
program what other programs are you
doing what are you doing that's
progressive in comparison that's how you
blow up your business it's imperative
that everybody understands they're in
the media business above and beyond
whatever the [ __ ] you do in here
that's how you get to the place of
creating the progressive principle
podcast and then that becomes the
gateway drug to the testimonials who
you're looking for because in that
interview just like Dee Brock and I are
doing eye contact on the you know things
were doing right this second you will be
talking to her she'll reference
something that you did to get her
attention
that's what you then clip where she's
naturally giving you a cosign not a
forced testimonial like we all hate
those testimonies it's like a weird
situation the person's wearing like a
timelike I like using Dee rocks video
work we like [ __ ] this you know
but but what you can imagine I apologize
is what I like about the principle
podcast is you're making something
directly for the person you're trying to
sell to I want to get to the decision
maker fat-fuck agencies go to the
decision maker or the person that
influences the decision maker the number
one mistake that people are making about
tick-tock right now is they don't
understand that teenage girls make moms
buy [ __ ] you win a fourteen-year-old
daughter you can sell shampoo to a mom
they go to literal they're like we don't
sell to fourteen year olds I'm like to
you sells in 42 year olds they're like
yes I'm like do you know who makes 42
year olds buy things their 14 year old
daughters cuz 42 year old women want to
act younger and they're making their
daughters friends not kids right so like
I want you to go to direct I want you to
make a show directly to who I wanted to
serve the progressive here's why I want
principals to want to be on your show
which inevitably means you're likely to
convert them on what you're actually
doing got it back to watch what we're
doing not we're saying we have on the
gallery media group side where we do
original podcast show called the CMO
podcast it's a good idea so I would do
that I think the progressive principle
angle is gonna lead to the most jet lead
gen for your prop product if they're the
decision maker if I'm hearing it right
that makes sense who by the way and I
think you'll know this anybody who's a
parent that's so involved is inevitably
also gonna be interested in hearing
about progressive principles because you
know parents love to hear something that
they can bang their principal on you
need to go listen to this principal
right so I think they both work for that
reason half follow you back and this and
that I got it I whether it's a podcast
or a video show I really think hosting
the party Oh
I've been pushing it for a while now you
know that it works you just got to do it
just like hey Alabama and hey Cleveland
you know like the Washington Nationals
pulled off a huge upset in baseball
right now and there are people in
Washington who are sales people that are
pumped about it and you could make a
video right now and be like you know how
you just stunned that like just like
Howie Kendrick hit a grand slam you can
hit a grand so like that will work is
that right that's amazing what's his
name
oh I know I know exactly who this is as
a matter of fact um man
Lew who's one of my admins is gonna lose
his mind he's like like a big big fan of
Corbin's that's awesome thank you so
much it's awesome
do you rock I don't want to lose it yes
gang what's been up at no storms this
season I know I saw the context there is
we were rocking and rolling and like
thank God we were rocking rolling
because they had a real storm
unfortunately come play is that right
that was rough good anything I can
answer I'm serious
we're going back to retail oh [ __ ]
yep brought everything up was just cheap
cheap cheap and so I think kind of where
my trouble is right now oh right I mean
I make sense
the second you show people that you will
go away from your word because you've
lost the leverage because you didn't
move something is the second you start
dying it's the number one flaw that Wine
Library did the last decade and I've
completely taken them away from it as
I've gotten a little more involved to
like customers are smartest [ __ ] they'll
just wait for the you know tent sale
sounds awesome
except when everyone gets into a
behavior of waiting for it because it
used to be once a year and now it's once
a quarter or whatever it may be right
it's all about I always tell why I
recently been yelling I'm like I'd
rather die with that [ __ ] wine then
to show the audience the customer that
we're willing to bend when we don't sell
enough cuz then they won't trust
anything that you and there's also
repackaging bundling I mean I'd rather
you know look laws with alcohol are
pretty tricky but I'd rather donate wine
to the local PTA events like I'd rather
give that [ __ ] furniture to the
homeless and let the local news and call
the new local news you see where I'm
going can't give up the leverage we're
too smart it's why so many of the
companies in retail are dead they became
sales oriented and we weren't just like
why do you think free shipping is
mandatory we they did it too much we
waited they got caught you got to hold
the line
yeah and what do you saying yeah what
are you seeing anything interesting I
mean it's our only the other thing I'm
obsessed with with your story you might
remember this you've so much square
footage I can't I mean this is the
number one thing I'm thinking about my
dad's second floor is a complete waste
of time
people don't like go on a second floor
when we just have a ton more foot
traffic like every retail establishment
did people that worked because people
went upstairs on Saturdays and really
shop premium wine the foot traffic set
up like it's just not the same and I'm
like I like this is not that you want to
go real funny like I literally right now
between wine texts and helping out like
I've really fixed the business so right
now have a ton of permission I literally
caught mine I was like I think I want to
turn the second floor into a baseball
card store he's like okay he's just so
he's just so happy so like like I I
still think that you guys turning part
of your store into a we work into a
sports bar like I will push you on this
every time it's your biggest asset that
is underutilized I think every book club
every PT like you should become the
community center of you don't need it as
much as you have it cut out that you
know store within store like [ __ ] it go
to the three hottest stores in town the
ice cream store the I can be like you
want a second location I'll charge you
nothing it's an asset
it's an asset you've got a you've got a
chicken
by the way I'll go on a call you know I
know I have to run to Atlanta soon for a
speech but like I'll call I'll do a call
with you we can keep innovating like you
have to turn that natori into an asset
correct the x-factor is going crazy
why can't you build a stage in the
middle of your thing and do open mic mic
for all local talent
you could you'll have to use Facebook to
get them to even know that's the thing
but I'm telling you right now the atomic
bomb in your business I believe is your
square footage internally and I do think
and this is gonna seem like a
contradiction I do think you should look
into texting and I think you should have
a weekly text deal but I think have to
be smart what the deal is so it doesn't
undermine your core and do something
that's a little bit more engaging
yeah because coupons can die real fast
if people just don't value the coupon
discounting is a is a drug and it can
turn out bad I remembered you know if
you remember it came so natural to me
because I'm like I get it
I know I retired honestly with between
being the way my dad built his visits
between retail between garage sale and
auction culture like I remember you guys
breaking it all day I remember a lot so
I remember a lot of it I remember
thinking like man I wish the action must
have been fun at its heyday just to go
there too I'm sure people want just the
action I think you need to turn your
place into a community event I think you
need the hack you need to get very
creative why why can't kids come and
Easter egg and pumpkin pick in your
store like I'm being I'm being serious
it sounds crazy but I'm like why
couldn't you buy or forget about buy why
couldn't you
the people that sell pumpkins wherever
say hey let's make a deal I want you to
give me a hundred pumpkins I'm gonna put
them throughout our store I'm gonna
spend a hundred dollars on Facebook ads
saying we got pumpkins from this that
will tag you come this Saturday for free
pumpkin you know like that's a really by
the way that's a really good answer to
that idea and the rock will tell you
like all I want to do is ID eight and
then try to make it operationally
practical if I was a partner I'd be like
[ __ ] it
we've got employees standing around all
day Monday will clean up the [ __ ]
cushions on Monday instead of jerking
off that's what I would say that's what
literally I would say I'd be like
[ __ ] Mario and Nick and Sarah will
[ __ ] actually work on Monday instead
of standing around waiting for somebody
to come in that would be the answer
that's how I think operationally but
you'd but you didn't say no in that
scenario you worried about the
ramifications and then I said by the way
you might be in a place where you don't
have that many making assumptions here
but if you have employees well good
Monday Monday morning and retail is not
the busiest [ __ ] thing of all time
we'll clean them up then but having
[ __ ] 100 families come to our store
for the first time in months maybe or
even ever heard about it
there's a good thing for us so the
biggest frustration I had it you know I
like picking on my dad because we see
things differently I create this program
two years ago you might remember do you
I think you remember this too where we
were doing free food at Wine Library on
Facebook events and it [ __ ] crushed
but because my dad saw couple people and
this is the best part of story because
they were Russians cuz he knows how
Russians work trick the system to come
back in and get another $20 worth of
free food he killed the whole thing he
couldn't stomach it meanwhile it was
building his business because even
though we were losing on the food we
were acquiring customers the store was
busy even the fact that the store looked
packed on a Saturday that I normally
didn't because we're on a very busy road
made more people just come to see
was going on but nope the emotion of
somebody double dipping Igor
trying to break the system made my
[ __ ] dad kill it retail is in deep
[ __ ] everything retail needs to do is
figure out how to get people to [ __ ]
come in permanently like a stage or a we
work or you're a promotions for fun
locally idea machine and you take
advantage of Facebook and Instagram
locally to drive awareness and
conversion that is the framework you
have to do or you go super macro and go
store within store and you lease out
yeah I remember yep which is even
scarier for me I want you have less
space if I could chop off Wine Library
second floor I would I can't
but going laterally I'd be condensing
and [ __ ] putting up a wall and
leasing and have a set like retail is in
trouble I don't have to explain to you
what way fear and all this stuff is the
trends are not coming back